[Applause]
we
are free people chance this crowd during
the coronavirus pandemic they say
wearing a mask and adhering to
restrictions is violating that freedom
and it seems thousands agree a mixture
of conspiracy theorists far-right
figures and citizens concerned by the
economic effects of the lockdown
took to the streets of berlin to say the
coronavirus has been a false alarm
that's just plain scare tactics i don't
see any danger
i don't know any sick people i knew many
sick people in march
skiers vacationers there was really
something going on in february
but now there's no sick people anymore
i've got a friend who is 93 she's in a
care home
in her room totally isolated there's no
corona in her home
and yet she wasn't allowed to leave her
room
now she's allowed to go out for a walk
again but if she meets someone
she has to give their address i think
that's extreme
our demand is back to democracy get rid
of the laws that restrict us
get rid of the masks that turn us into
slaves
hardly any of the demonstrators were
wearing face masks or adhering to social
distancing protocols
berlin police attempted to enforce
distancing measures over megaphones
eventually dissolving the protests and
telling people to go home
german politicians mostly condemned the
demonstration
saying that it risks harming germany's
relative success at handling the
outbreak
that success might just be why these
people feel impatient to get back to
normal life
but with a fresh spike in coveted cases
across the country
a gathering of thousands of people not
wearing masks
could jeopardize the freedoms germans
are enjoying compared to many other
countries
hit by the pandemic
well with me in the studio now is dw
political correspondent leonie von
hammerstein
who is at the protest mooney you are out
there for hours
you told me um you spoke to lots of
people there
what were they telling you what were
their demands
well there were a lot of different
people out there and as you said we
spoke to many of them
some of their demands included including
by the organizers who
who put their demands in the document
before the event i'm saying
calling on that that was the end of the
pandemic they called this the day of
freedom
and they then called on the german
government to resign
and on the state the public broadcasters
so the media to also be dissolved and
these were the three demands that were
echoed by many people who i spoke to at
the protest
and what united them was a distrust in
the government's measures and
we have to remember this is kind of a
paradox you said it just now
and a lot of the people were telling me
well and the government was telling us
that we have to
keep our distance and stick to all these
restrictions
in order for the hospitals not to be
overcrowded in order for people not to
die
but nobody died not that many people
died the hospitals are still empty
and so what did the government tell us
in the first place
and this is why this is this inherent
distrust in what the government is
telling them
and that's why you saw i saw today
thousands tens of thousands of people
take to the streets
not adhering to the rules not adhering
to the face masks
and they kind of use a lot of them were
telling me they they see the face mask
as sort of that symbol of oppression
that the government is forcing them to
wear masks i mean we also have to
remember germany has released a lot of
its measures a lot of its restrictions
and in recent weeks which has as you
said we've seen a search in
new infections so enormous amounts of
distrust of the government but who
are these people loney i mean i'm
wondering because lots of people are
quite grateful to the german government
for its swift response to the pandemic
and the measures that it implemented
they're grateful that it saved lives but
these people who
don't believe that who are they well
they're also
um you can't there's a wide variety of
people who attended these um
protests today and what we can say
some people were talking to me there
were people who were worried about the
economic consequences of the pandemic
there was a bus driver from croatia who
told me
well i haven't been able to run my
business for four months how should i
survive
there have been people who are worried
about their children not being able to
go back to school
which they are but the education system
being changed i'm
worried about what this pandemic will
leave what kind of country
will it leave to the children but we
also have to say that
um far-right groups have been mobilizing
for this protest not only the afd
the party that sits in the biggest
opposition party in the german bundestag
also the npd
um compact magazine magazine which is a
far-right magazine that's under the
observation of the authorities
for example and revisionist messages
conspiracy theorists i talked to some
people who
believed um that bill gates wanted to um
spread to vaccinate the whole the whole
world so really these conspiracy
theories that we are not only seeing in
germany but also
across the world for where people um use
this pandemic to feed into these
conspiracy theories
a lot of them also anti-semitic
backgrounds we saw
um some placards there today so it's
hard to say i i'd say the majority was
peaceful but i'd also say we got a lot
of verbal
abuse from protesters who were calling
us liars
and we were calling um as ludenpresser
so you know
lying press i mean that's echoing nazi
terminology is it not
yes exactly leonie von hammerstein thank
you so much for your reporting and for
sharing your impressions with us in the
studio thank you